you do go where or do you do other
situation i
i wasn't able to go out and work
i do feel like that i should work
okay
what kind of working are you going to be
doing like seemed like cooking
as before
so
i talked with my friend rohit in order
to restart our food business and he want
me to start right after when we come
back from my honeymoon but
uh jenny is like uh retired already and
she is
ready to live alive in a retired way
basically uh but i'm in my 30s and like
i feel like that i'm productive i can do
a job i can
make money so i don't i should do that
well what's your plan like uh
maybe i'll off on monday
or tuesday once in a week
uh once in a week
you're gonna work every day except one
day six days a week is too much
i have money too coming in now i get my
retirement and i sell security and so
you i'm not gonna depend only on you
you're my husband and we need to be
together more than just one day a week
hardly i go anywhere without you
okay but i mean i didn't come on this
honeymoon for you to tell me how much
you're gonna be away from me
i've sacrificed a lot to come and live
here with cement in india
and i worked hard my whole life
and i want to relax and enjoy my life
with my husband
i mean i didn't fight this hard to marry
smith so that he can go off and work six
days a week and leave me home alone
and i don't know why smitt wants to
bring this up on our honeymoon this
isn't a good time to talk about work
kind of takes the romance out of the
honeymoon
[Music]
you